there are two very different thrillers
battling it out at the box office this
weekend the new Godzilla and MA starring
Oscar winner Octavia Spencer like you
have never ever seen her before this
battle box somewhere how did she get our
numbers I always like doing movies that
will educate and there is some education
to be gleaned from this don't make me
drink
no don't make me drink oh and kids
should know not be hanging out with
adults a period you know Octavia is the
sinister and very creepy ma in her new
horror flick befriended then terrorizing
an unsuspecting group of teenagers but
playing the psychopath wasn't the
scariest part of shooting this movie you
have a make-out scene mm-hmm mm-hmm
what was that like he looks 15 but he
was really 18 okay that was still very
very very very strange he smelled just
like her daddy that's what you have to
call on the character you know because
Octavian like MA
isn't the only monster in theaters this
weekend
the legendary Godzilla returns and this
time the fate of humanity hangs in the
balance
Millie Bobby Brown makes her feature
film debut alongside Kyle Chandler Vera
Farmiga and O'Shea Jackson jr. and we
found out this fifteen-year-old is wise
beyond her years
your prankster oh yes I actually never
pranked you never because I was I was
honestly quite frightened I just didn't
know what like what would happen then it
would stop a wall with him and I just
didn't think that that was smart
this was Millie's feature film debut
Millie Bobby Brown is 38 years old yeah
she's uh she's seasoned already you know
mentally she's just at least 38 oh yeah
it's all old hat to her she is wise
beyond her years
okay she's 15 thank you the crazy fence
yeah by the way also opening this
weekend Rocketman look if anyone could
go toe-to-toe with mah and Godzilla it
would be Elton John
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]